That wasn't very nice, Nobi.
I'm leaving!
To think, his wedding is tomorrow.
Time flies.
Looks like our little Nobi's all grown up.
I can't help but wonder where he's gone.
I wish I could see my grandma one last time.
If I could see your future wife,...
...that would be enough to content my heart.
So tell us why you ran away from the wedding.
I mean, just look at me.
What if I'm not good enough?
What if I don't have what it takes to make Sue happy?
I gotta go.
There's no time.
I'll be back as soon as I save us.
There's no time to waste!
I know Nobi is going to make it here no matter what.
I am going to take back my future with Sue no matter what it takes.
All of your moments with Big G, Sneech and Sue will be gone.
You're fine just the way you are, Nobi.